la manifestation propalestinienne qui a
été autorisée hier soir in extrémist
place de la République à Paris d'abord
systématiquement interdite une décision
de justice est venue casser cette
interdiction je pense qu'on était tous à
peu près d'accord ici pour dire que
c'est vrai que voilà c'est c'est c'est
c'était c'était assez normal et c'était
C c'était normal qu' qu'onon qu'on qu'on
autorise cette manifestation qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez moi je trouve c'est
une bonne décision du Conseil d'État de
casser justement la volonté de
l'interdiremich parce qu'on est toujour
dans un deux poids de mesure je trouve
beaucoup le camp palestin a tendance à
dire bah oui mais nous on nous laisse
pas manifester je trouvais ça bien moi
qu'on les laisse manifester et après on
on va voir ce qui se passe et comment ça
se passe mais pas à priori comme ça
alors une manifestation qui s'est tenue
dans le calme mais qui a fait l'objet de
beaucoup de débats il y a eu la vidéo
d'un policier violent avec un
manifestant il y a eu des slogans Israël
assassin Macron complice Allah Akbar
aussi scandé par les participants est-ce
qu'il y a eu de vraies dérives ou pas a
priori de ce qu'on me dit que ça s'est
tenu plutôt dans le calme Gill oui oui
il y a eu des slogans mais c'était
plutôt assez calme avec très peu
d'interpellations voilà il y avait
beaucoup de monde beaucoup de monde et
la police est évidemment retirée une
fois qu'un extrémist la manifestation a
été autorisée les policiers étaient prêt
à agir mais ils se sont retirés on aur
regardz c'était hier place de la
République à
parisousm
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
on va voir Camille Laman qui est pas
encore là malheureusement il est en
retard donc voilà c'est malheureusement
et il y a Nasser bouuera qui est avec
nous merci Nasser d'être avec nous juste
on va revenir sur tout ce qui s'est
passé hier donc la manifestation était
autorisée 18h il y a eu énormément de
monde qui est arrivé et euh les
manifestants ont effectué une minute de
silence place de la République en
soutien au civil tué dans la bande de
Gaza on a eu également après la minute
de silence les 4000 manifestants ont
allumé les lumières de leur téléphone
[Applaudissements]
regardez
alors euh Gilles euh il y a y a les
manifestants qui qui seondent Allah
Akbar euh excusez-moi ça ve ça veut dire
Dieu est grand ou oui mais c'est ça en
fait comprends alors je me mets je sais
pas me dire mais moi je je pose les
questions euh en fait c'est on dit
souvent que les terroristes disent ça
avant de commettre avant de passer à
l'acte mais pass tous les musulmans ont
le droit de dire euh dieu est grand non
c'est ça que je comprends pas en fait
parce que comme ça a été utilisé par des
terroristes on a on a pas le droit de de
l'utiliser en manifestation je vous pose
la question parce que vous êtes voilà
vous êtes musulmans et moi en fait je
comprends pas que c'est pu choquer des
gens c'est ça que en fait j'arrive pas à
comprendre j'étais avec un pote
avantiier aussi il me dit mais à ça veut
dire Dieu est grand donc c'est pas c'est
pas enfin c'est c'est pas c'est pas un
appel au crime non voilà de fait
énormément de gens on étaient choqués et
moi je suis comme vous je ne comprends
pas parce que Dieu est grand ça a été
détourné par les terroristes c'est les
terroristes qui se sont approprié cette
expression qui n'a rien à voir avec le
terrorisme et du coup maintenant les
musulmans qui disent à àakbar Dieu est
grand ou Dieu est le plus grand
énormément de fois en priant ou qu' le
disent dans la vie quotidienne du coup
ils ont l'impression d'être inféodé au
terroristes on a renverser totalement
l'expression et moi je suis extrêmement
choqué que des gens éent été choqués je'
pas compris ici autour de la table dites
la vérité voilà parce que moi en fait
j'arrive je comprends pas pas compris
est-ce qu' y en a que ça choque dit la
vérité
oui pourquoi Jacques alors ben parce que
je suis troublé par effectivement le
fait que euh c'est un c'est un chant qui
est enfin un chant un appel je pas c'est
un mot un CH Oui une expression merci
une expression qui est rappelée à chaque
fois qu'il s'agit de tuer quelqu'un donc
la symbolique bah elle elle a en tous
les cas été récupérée comme telle par
ceux qui commettent le jihad donc si tu
veux peut-être détourner comme tel mais
le fait qu'elle soit reprise aujourd'hui
par 4000 personnes en plein Paris au
moment où on enterre le professeur à
quelques kilomètres de là moi ça me
choque je m'interroge je ne sais pas ce
qu'il y a derrière ben je ne sais pas je
je dis ça me choque pour cette raisonlà
je ne sais pas je suis curieux
d'entendre tout ce que vous allez dire
parce que je m'interroge est-ce que
quelles sont les motivations de ceux qui
disent cela qui qui reprennent ce ce
cette
expression est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose de béliqueux est-ce qu'il y a une
envie derrière est-ce que c'est une
revanche cont l'é français que c'est un
AFF mais Jacques j'en sais rien sais'
mais moi franchement alors là je je
trouve que c'est chercher des pou
excusez-m bien s oui c'est s qu'est-ce
que tu en penses mooun en fait ils le
reprennent pas c'est pas ça avait déjà
été utilisé avant parce que ça veut dire
Dieu est grand et il l'utilisait avant
et ils l'utiliseront après parce que
c'est une expression qui est utilisée
même dans les prières et qui est
utilisée de manière hyper
commune c'est enfin je veux dire on peut
pas empêcher à des gens de dire quelque
chose sous prétexte que des des des T
l'ont dit dans d'autres mesures il
s'agit pas d'empêcher il s'agit de
s'interroger sur le sens que veulent
donner ceux qui le crient à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce que tu en penses vous mélangez
tout tout au départ c'est donc non mais
tu es d'accord avec moi ou tu es
d'accord ai moi je moi je suis je suis
d'accord avec la paix je suis d'accord
avec l'amour c'est c'est qu' c'est qu'un
mot et derrière ce mot il y a rien il y
a rien on mélange
tout on est en train
de d'interpréter on est en train de de
juger une religion chaque matin vous
mettez BFM C news toutes les
informations toute la journée Islam
Islam vous étiez hier soir à la
manifestation non non d'accord vous
est-ce que vous savez qui sont les 4000
personnes qui étaient là hier il y a
plein de gens comme moi qui on a rien à
faire de tout ça on veut juste vivre en
paix on a assez tous les matins vous
vous réveillez vous mettez des vous
mettez les les les chaînes on parle
encore de l'islam toujours de l'islam
toujours des mauvais faux français
toujours des des des cas mais parlez-moi
d'amour parlez-moi de paix parlez-moi de
par moi je je te vois des mot d'amour
moi ça coûte cher on l' beaucoup fait
sur ce plateau de parler d'amour de P
bien
par transmettez de la paix transmettez
vire ensble il y des G qui meurent y des
G qui sont
des is auourd en des G
qui parler d'amour pas peut parler
d'amour malureus y a plein de choses
important tous les jours gens qui
crèvent de faim gens qui
peuvent quel regard vous portez sur quel
regard vous portez sur ce qui s'est
passé je je suis triste je suis triste
pour pour pour pour les deux camp ça me
bouleverse quand quandand quand j'ai vu
ces ces maumes par terre sans tête ça me
bouleverse quand j'ai vu les gamins sous
des gravass à Gaza ça bouleverse des
deux côtés moi je suis touché parce que
j'ai j'ai des amis d'enfance de 40 ans
j'ai des potes israéliens avec qui j'ai
bossé au komè pendant des années à autre
part qui aujourd'hui vont envoyer leur
gamins qui ont 21 ans à l'armée aux
frontières diff c ça fait plaisir quand
j'ai ma copine Rebecca ou mon copain IAL
qui me dit mon fils va là vous croyez
que ça fait plaisir à moi quand je vois
les quand j'entends ou quand je lis ou
quand je vois un gamin sous les desces
quand je vois un PS parler un PS un ptit
goui parler un enfant qui qui esttanisé
qui qui qui
qui on on va se retrouver dans un
instant on mais c'est vrai que je vrais
vous dire on dit à Labar même quand il y
a une naissance
c'estand bien sûr à la fin d'une
conversation quand on a une émotion
quand y quand il y a une personne qui a
guéri on la famille ex on va se
retrouver dans un instant les chéris
voilà voilà mais non c'est c'est pour
c'est je sais pas voilà expression de la
vie
quotidienne ça pas de signification onou
dans un instant à tout suite